um so what are we talking about
do we need to talk about jojo do we
really need to talk about george do you
want to talk about your part
to read seven yeah uh i haven't actually
read julian yet but it's about to end as
at the time of uh recording this they
just announced that it's gonna end next
month yeah next month i'm probably going
to speed run reading to jolie on yeah i
so that i can talk about it
like i'm i think i'm like one volume
behind right now and it's pretty [ __ ]
good so far i'm surprised they're ending
it this
soon though because i'm not going to go
in i've heard that it was not too long
ago that we got introduced to the main
villain so yeah i'm not gonna i don't
wanna i don't wanna say anything because
i don't know anything that's just what i
know so because everyone was telling me
that it had so much much left but
whatever i'm gonna i'm probably gonna
read it i might make a video about it i
don't know if i should on my main
channel it's pretty good maybe i will
maybe i'll i wouldn't say it's as good
as i think it would be on brand for you
right yeah it'd be on brand for you i in
my opinion it's not as good as like
seven part six or seven but it's up
there it's still pretty good it's jojo
we'll see how we'll see how this uh how
your feelings will change in the news
yeah i mean i don't know like the ending
of jesus might be [ __ ] amazing right
yeah true who knows but yeah jojo i mean
i mean it was the jojo manga that made
you a jojo fan right yeah so it was
definitely i was watching part five
and i wanted more of part five because
it hadn't fully aired yeah we were only
like ten episodes in and i was really
enjoying it
so i went and picked up the manga and i
just [ __ ] loved it like i said such a
great time um
it's a shame that it's the english
official releases are quite slow mm-hmm
um i think we're they just finished
part four
yeah i mean like really yeah oh geez
like a lot of people forget that jojo
just like was this super [ __ ]
underground manga that only like a
select few people really read before the
anime became a thing and so there was
dust yeah in the west and so like there
was just no interest to translate it
officially until the anime came out now
it's weird seeing it become this like
massive one of the most biggest anime
franchises
i made a video on what was it it was
like i had this series like back in the
it's like five years ago i had this
series where i would like go into manga
and like kind of find like myths and
like kind of secrets and stuff like that
and kind of talk about it yeah i
remember i made a video on it was part
three oingo boingo and there's that like
you know the moment
i made a video on that five years ago no
views
no views at all i was like oh my god and
that's when i realized i was like oh no
one in the west knows jojo yeah
at that point i feel like jojo was such
a 50 50 on whether it would do well yeah
i think it just i'm really surprised
that it did it just got i think it just
got lucky with the with the memes i
think so yeah it was it was like it was
like so perfected for meme culture that
it was like so ahead of its time yeah
and it's it's really weird because you
it wasn't really memed until part three
yeah yeah the anime came out i guess i
feel like i i did not see anything about
it until part three came out and then i
saw i never stopped uh seeing the d.o
versus jotaro like steam sale memes you
know
you'd see a ton of memes with the aurora
and all that yeah yeah yeah that's when
it really started picking up steam i
think and then it started i then i think
the um people started realizing how good
the anime adaptation was and then part i
remember it really kicked off during
part four yeah airing in the west was
when it started really getting some
steam yeah and then part five just like
insane
yeah the part five anime adaptation of
jojo really like centered into like this
like because the [ __ ] jordano's theme
yeah did numbers for the meme community
oh yeah yeah and jojo in general i mean
how many people got into part jojo in
general
from the journal's team yeah because i
mean
it's like the um what was the undertale
theme uh megalovan
yeah it's it's up there with megalovania
in terms of like obviously
that's the anime community yeah right
because think of like iconic meme music
that came out in the past 10 years
what have you got there like actual like
iconic like super iconic chinese theme
megalovania there's probably some other
that i'm forgetting
yeah there wasn't really an explosion of
like jojo never exploded you you just
slowly crept up in popularity until you
couldn't you couldn't like it was
inescapable yeah
escape five really helped since part
five started airing it really blew up
yeah i feel like a noticeable change
yeah in my opinion part five is probably
one of the only parts where it's
actually better in the anime yeah yeah
part four i think you can go either all
part four is yeah either three three two
and one hundred percent the market yeah
you can you can get through it at a good
pace yeah um but the part three of the
anime is very slow which i think jojo in
general is better in manga also because
you have part six and seven which are
very good part seven being especially
notorious for being just amazing
part seven is possible is amazing part
seven is where i feel like iraqi really
came into his own and finally made like
the perfect jojo part where there was no
pacing issues yeah i feel like every
part of jojo had some kind of weird
pacing at some point or another every
character was fun and like memorable
yeah like so for example like part three
it drags out a bunch part two is very
short and sweet you don't really get too
much but it's very nice and that's why
part two is i mean joseph's the only
redeeming factor about that joseph's
right the villains boring yeah right
part one
i mean it's no touristy
it's quite boring i won't lie it has a
lot of charm as a jojo but at least it's
short all right it's very short you can
read through it part four
kira who is the arguably one of the best
villains in jojo isn't there for the
first half so you kind of get a slice of
life for the first part which is which
is fun but it takes a while for it to
kind of find its footage yeah if if
you're not a fan of that kind of stuff
then
you can easily like fall off it yeah and
be like why is this popular yeah why do
people like this um plot five is very
solid uh i think that uh jordano is one
of the weaker joe joe bros
um and then part six you know it's good
it also has a bit of a controversial
ending um i really i like it but some
people don't like it i can understand
why people wouldn't like it i feel that
some parts of part six are a little weak
but part seven is like from start to
finish banger every single character
banger like the villains even like the
side villains i mean it is it does have
kind of the least memorable jojo's
though uh johnny uh yeah i don't know i
feel like johnny doesn't get good till
like the last quarter maybe johnny comes
into his own yeah yeah but i feel like
jono doesn't really come into his own no
at any point no sorry if we're going on
a whole thought about jojo
just just talk about it jojo fans being
jojo fans exactly right you need to read
it because then you can experience part
seven which you should 100 read it is
amazing no you can't skip to it don't do
that yeah because part 7 has so many
references to previous parts you'd be
spoiling it read it all it's amazing